you were brought on board for the last
exorcism right before production and it
almost has like this feel of like a
minor league baseball player getting a
call for the majors right before the
playoffs tell us about how that
opportunity came about and where you
were in your life at that time what we
have made necessary death but it hasn't
really it was kind of this thing that
existed on a DVD that was passed around
in the industry no audience had action
scene and someone I studied with at AFI
screenwriter was writing something for a
production company and overheard this
conversation that one of the producers
said our directors are doing another
movie that just jumped ship where do we
find another director who can do fake
documentaries and I had just a week
prior to that had given him a DVD of a
necessary death for some bizarre reason
I have to feel like he should see this
movie dinner and he had it in his bag
and he just gave it to the producer and
said check this out and they liked the
style and then they invited me in
and asked me if I could make a horror
movie and that's where that comes in the
confidence thing that you have to fake
because I'm not a horror movie guy
necessarily you know i don't i don't
have vast knowledge in horror so when
they asked me that I just had to fake it
and I just had to say of course I can
make a horror movie no problem I've
learned that much about Hollywood that
you know someone asks you if you can do
something you say yes with confidence
and then sweat on the way back home
we've got like what did I just get
myself into but you try to figure it out
step by step and that's how I then
became the director of that movie was
very quick process
you